I've got some breaking news to tell you
about from Turkey the country's interior
minister Solomon Sulu has resigned this
two days after a two-day lockdown was
announced for 31 cities in Turkey
al Jazeera sanam Co Sulu is on the line
now from Istanbul said my as the
minister resigned has been almost half
an hour ago he announced his resignation
on his official Twitter account saying
that he is taking all responsibility for
what happened on Friday night as you
also said on Friday night in the make a
late hours Interior Minister announced
that there would be a 48-hour lockdown
for 31 cities it's so far Turkish
president aired on has been against the
ideal collect on a special for Istanbul
as it's the economic capital of the
country
but the weather has been very nice for
the last couple of days and people were
going down and even last Friday was a
very busy day for truck Istanbul traffic
as if there was no coronavirus threat in
Turkey that's why the Health Ministry
defense Science Board and interior
ministry have urged for this lockdown
however the circular the lockdown wasn't
announced tonight any ously with the
with the lockdown that's why people
stopped in to see from workers thousands
of people there to buy bread the
bakeries and supermarkets were poor
people violated all that a social
distance rules that they have to obey
and they were it was a chaos in short
and many criticize the government that
were not announcing it properly and if
we're not warning the people the
citizens on time that the bakeries would
be open during that lockdown in those
search once it is basically he he was
accused of accused for the scales and
yesterday he apologized from everyone
and today in his resignation note on
social media he said that he's taking
all responsibility and he said the
president they should accept this
resignation issues accept his apology so
so far we we have no idea whether the
Turkish president Georgia played by Baal
has accepted interior ministry ministers
designation but I must say that for
Turkey that has also been fighting
against the outlawed Kurdistan Workers
Party which Turkey has designated as a
terrorist group it is not good news
because süleyman's only the interior
minister has has been well known for his
efforts to fight against what the
country called terrorism and he has been
harsh on the measures
sinem many thanks indeed our Jazeera
simcha co2 there on Turkey's interior
minister who has resigned after a curfew
was announced at the last minute causing
panic buying across the country many
thanks to them